e
e e
good
morning welcome to Edna
uh we're I'm opening the public hearing
on House Bill 180 and I call
Representative PR who will give us a
card when he's after he speaks
will what a
shame good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
Mark PR Hillsboro 15 which is Ward 8 in
Manchester I come to you today uh with a
an amendment
with an
amendment to the
amendment kind
of and I thought this was such a simple
bill it wouldn't need an amendment
apparently I was
wrong the amendment is just adding a
definition of a team
leader uh so that people understand what
that job
is the original reason I I opened this
up again is
the international critical incident
stress Foundation decided to come up
with a money maker in the form of a
certification
test um that costs
$400 for the privilege of taking this
test after you've taken their
course
um and it doesn't do
anything other than say you took the
test
because even if you don't pass it you're
not getting kicked off a team
um and so we found it unnecessary that
this language was in there that if
somebody said well everybody has to be
certified all of our team members are
volunteers they have jobs they have
other thing and as soon as uh this kind
of came out that this was happening a
lot of team members reached out to me uh
and said we can't afford to do that we
won't be able to be on the team and I
said take a deep breath we'll figure
this out I had other teams call me and
said
hey this is really expensive I don't
think we can do this and and I and I
don't believe it's necessary right in
the teams we're doing training we're
making PE sure our our members are up to
date on their skills um we travel in a
group when we do these things uh we have
a mental health professional also when
we're doing these things um either
depending on what we're doing whether
it's a a debriefing they're at the
debriefing if it's doing one-on-one uh
coaching and because we're not
counselors um we have that mental health
person that we can reach back to if we
have any questions concerns or anything
like that that they can help us with so
I don't believe this is really necessary
to have this certification test at
$400 um and I can give you
um a little background information about
the critical the international offline
if anybody wants to hear it but I don't
think I'm going to bore you all with
that and with that I'll I'll take any
questions
all right thank you are there are there
any
questions uh representative Lon and then
groda uh thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for bringing this to
us um I also see the amendment adds that
it may or may not be affiliated with the
municipality for the incident team is
that an issue you've run into or are you
just busy cleaning up the language while
we have it open clearing up the language
while we have it open my team used to be
Loosely affiliated with nashille fire
but not so much and we we actually
became an independent standing
team uh and I want to make sure that
that can still continue without anybody
saying well here a lot of people are
affiliated so you should be affiliated
with a department and and that's not
necessary follow up follow up and as a
followup does that make it easier for
your teams to provide services to more
more people who need it throughout the
state
so I our team the Grand State critical
incident stress management team was the
first team in the state approximately 40
years ago uh and we provided Services
throughout the state to police Fire EMS
emergency rooms any emergency responder
we took care of um and in the early days
we used to go to Maine Vermont
Massachusetts because we were one of the
only teams in the area now there are
more teams which is great uh that way we
have plenty of people to make sure
nobody gets missed
so thank you and thank you for what you
do thanks okay Reps for oh and then
Howard
okay thank you so
um what you're saying I just want to
make sure that I'm reading the bill
correctly you're saying the team members
shall undergo initial
training set forth by the
icif but you're at the bottom and C
below you're also saying the team
leadership shall be responsible training
team members sitting so the team the
team leaders training is different no
it's the same thing same thing they just
want to make
sure so you could
have critical incident stress for
groups or you could have it for
individuals most of us have both of
those classes because the uh icisf has
created what they call a grin class
where they take those two classes
usually they're three three days each
but when you put them together at the
same time a lot of the material overlaps
so they can do both classes in three
days thank you that's
helpful repr
power so uh thank you for taking my
question so uh similarly uh I understand
that we're taking out the uh sustaining
of certification standards how
frequently are those certification
standards uh met
when you take your class initially and
then in the teams themselves we do
continuing education to make sure people
are up on new things but other than that
no okay all right thank you yep other
questions he answered the
question thank you representative Schmid
no other questions thank you very much
you're welcome is there anyone else who
wishes to speak on House Bill
180 I guess not in that case I'm going
to close the public
hearing and since we have some
time uh let's go into executive session
and does somebody have a
motion repres L Madam chair um I'd move
a to pass with Amendment
to pass and move the amendment all right
um all right representative Schmidt
moves to ought to pass the amendment and
representative Lon
second we should probably note that it's
Amendment 0261 H
correct all right so any discussion on
the amendment
than
represent I think representative pu has
spoken to the amendment in a very
clarifying manner uh so that we
understand why and how and so forth so
okay you representative citech this is a
these people are self certified there's
no formal there's no state certification
that is correct there is an there's a
independent organ organization that
provides
training
and there is a there is a test available
if they wish to take
it but most of them
decline I presume you make
representative cre could I ask you if
you make sure that people who attend the
class actually know what they've
learned yes
okay representative re just for your
your background this is representative
PR is the state expert on critical
response management teams and he's been
before us several times creating this
structure and tweaking
it
so as I noticed your your little
confusion are there any other questions
or
comments okay then the motion is to
accept Amendment 02 61h to House Bill
180 clerk can call the role Vice
chairman L yes clerk votes
yes uh representative Bailey
I representative Sheen yes
representative
Ren yes
representative Schmid yes representative
DAV yes representative Dar
yes representative Howard
yes representative
yes chair
yes okay the amendment passes
representative schmidth you have a
motion
oh well i' I'd like to defer to
representative Lan who made the motion
originally thank you thank you I'd move
a to pass as amended by Amendment
0261 and thank you for getting me in
correct form
representative and it's with
Amendment with Amendment I'll second
okay move by representative Lon second
by representative broa any further
discussion not surprising since he
Amendment place the entire
Bill all right in that case the clerk
can call the role Vice chairman Le
yes clerk votes yes representative
Bailey I representative shim yes
representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Dar yes repres representative Howard yes
representative Reese yes chair yes 110
same 110 okay motion passes 11 to zero
does anyone have an objection to
consent seeing none we'll put that one
on
consent and we will come out of
executive session because all the other
bills we might consider need an
amendment that we don't
have we will resume at 10:30
I
try
e
e e
welcome back I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 438 and I call Representative
hor thank you very much Madam chair as I
am indeed represent Timothy Horan from
straford County District 10 which is the
town of Durham so I'm the prime and only
sponsor of HP
438 which is a uh well it's a uh L Bill
although I appear to be the only witness
speaking for it um first of all I I'll
mention I got an email this morning from
Maggie Fogerty from the American friends
service committee which by the way is an
organization I belong to or at least
occasionally uh send money into so uh
she she told me that she sent some email
testimony and I have not seen it but
hopefully hopefully the members of the
committee especially the clerk will
track down the email and make sure
that's in the bill file whatever so
whatever she said I'm sure
is uh is excellent probably better than
what I have prepared but anyway here
goes so this bill HB 438 is an update of
the second half of a bill which is I
think it was in this committee eight
years ago um HB 558 that bill didn't go
that far but that was mostly because of
problems with the first part of the bill
which dealt with for-profit prisons
although I should add dep parting a
little bit from written testimony that
actually that issue there was by far as
an interest in it and actually uh
not too long afterwards I think in 2021
a similar Bill actually was passed some
Republicans took up the issue and
Governor s had a ceremonial signing of
it so a a bill about for-profit prisons
was in fact passed not long afterwards
but anyway so uh then and now for-profit
prisons did not and do not exist in New
Hampshire but there were situations
where inmates need to be placed out of
state possibly in for-profit facilities
um the immigration detention faity was
relatively non controversial at the time
at least not not like it is now there
wasn't quite the U what I might almost
call hysteria over the issue um but
there was it still is only one
immigration Detention Facility New
Hampshire and that's straford County
Jail which is used for nonviolent
detainees whose only major alleged
offense was being in the country without
permission some of them are also brought
in for minor crimes but if you're like a
really uh if you're accused of something
really serious you don't go to the jail
they send you to other facilities so
it's um it's nonviolent offenders um a
few years ago I visited uh visited the
dormatory there the kept them and a lot
large number of those were just kept in
an old part of the jail in a uh you know
with fairly minimal supervision they
were hanging around watching I think a
soccer game on TV so they were
definitely not a they did not look like
a crowd of hardened criminals and they
were
but so um and actually straford County
Jail's business partially grow out of we
we've have a long standing
relationship with being a processing
point for federal detainees so we often
transfer them from the state system to
the federal system um at straford County
anyway my bill simply mandated best
practices which the jail was already
honoring for various reasons not the
least of which was the fact that the
jail was contractually obligated to
follow those practices anyway but also
because U they're the right thing to do
and it makes you know just makes life
easier for you know both the correction
staff and the detainees so first of all
this bill updates the previous 2017 Bill
to refer to the current uh 2025
additions of various documents and
regulations
um far as I know all those regulations
are still in place you know there's a
lot of uncertainty what's going on
Washington DC but we should assume that
all those various regulations are still
operative and frankly it does go further
and U an attempt to pre prevent some of
the abuses inherent in president Trump
threatened Mass deportations so
immigration detention phys will not be
allowed to detain citizens of the United
States um they must not be large to
detain large numbers of people based
solely on ethnicity or National Origins
so you have to be detaining People based
on what they individually are doing
facilities must be under civilian
control if they're authorized by the
state they also must not be operated by
for-profit entities and that you know
that in line with the overall lack of
for profit prisons here in New Hampshire
um unfortunately we don't really have
the power to stop the Federal government
from operating its own
facilities within our within our borders
but we would if this bill becomes law
would be routinely asking the feds to
inform us of the existence of such
facilities and finally the governor
cannot deploy would not be able to
deploy the National Guard for
immigration deportation activities
without the consent of the executive
Council so the purpose of all this aside
from Simply you know continuing to obey
the best practices we've been obeying is
also prevent or at least discourage the
state government cooperating with any ma
future Mass deportation campaigns so I I
would just frankly say Mass deportation
is contrary to our tradition of
Tolerance and Live Free or Die so I I
urge you to uh I urge you urge you so I
urge you to pass this bill especially
you know I'm seeing probably the parts
that like um are the same as my just an
update of my previous Bill especially
shouldn't be controversial at all and we
should you know so I urge you to pass
the bill with that I'd be happy to take
any questions thank you represent Horgan
are there any questions from the
committee president Bailey
yeah thank you um in response to a
question not too long ago straford
County Commissioner mclara says there is
no
contract they have an agreement
okay okay that's the does that affect
this at all when you mentioned
contractual obligations that's probably
fair enough but we are Prov the services
and the federal government is paying for
it so there's a you implied contract
there so
probably I mean if you probably whatever
represent commission well he used to be
a representative commissioner McClair so
he he's not here today to to clarify
that I have heard him talking about it
we're both on the executive committee so
it's a fair question um possibly
possibly the committee might want to
reach out to them before reaches a final
decision on the pill and you know have
him you know it would be would have been
you know he's got a lot of this things
to do it would have certainly been very
good to have him here and if I've made
an error I apologize and I'm sure he
would politely but firmly set set me
straight on that but I mean but there is
at least an implied contract we're
taking money and we're providing the
services to the federal government
so and thank you and they wouldn't pay
us if we weren't following these
regulations okay we Leon thank you madam
chair and thank you representative are
you concerned that you're inserting a
new St uh chapter in our statute that to
me reads like it's allowing the state to
create immigration detention facilities
and are you worried about the Legacy
that might lead leave you in the future
when uh policies change well I I would
prer that we not not not regulate we
would not create them but I think it's
probably better have some Protections in
place uh you know rather than not have
them since it is a possibility I mean I
would prefer um you we don't have
private prisons here in New Hampshire
and I guess NE detention facilities is
not quite the same thing as a private
prison but um and certainly would be so
I would I would like to have at least
some framework for regulating them in
place so I'm I'm comfortable with adding
another chapter to our law book which
already has hundreds of chapters in it
anyway you can see
how I guess it's not over here in the
corner room but it's you know it's a
very large volume very large set of
volumes thank you other
questions seeing none thank you
representative
fory representative groa
thank you Madame chair I'm here to
present an amendment to House Bill
538 which was drafted by Representative
Patrick long and I'm here presenting it
as a draft on his
behalf I asked him to look at House Bill
438 because he is an immigration assur
attorney and I thought his input would
be valuable for the committee he did
strike out certain Clauses in the bill
the first one if you want to look at
house bill I I took the liberty of
looking at his draft and looking at the
bill and I thought it might be
beneficial for you if I just noted
it he remov section D1 which talks about
the prohibition of private
contracts he removes section
four which
describes the immigration Detention
Facility operator as an an agent of the
immigration Detention Facility um the
immigration Detention Facility operator
is also defined in three and he prefers
the the definition in three rather than
four he removed Clause five which talks
about involuntary placement in
segregated because of their or his
actual gender gender identity he removed
that part on line 32 where it says Mass
deportation of immigrants he replaced
that phrase with actually it's not a
phrase he replaced that quotation with
segregated housing and those are the
changes that were made on the
amendment and he replac he asks that we
look at the amendment and replace the
amendment in
whole I don't know if you have any
questions I'm not going to be
so he tottally rewrote the chapter
correct
exactly
okay representative Le um thank you
madam chair and thank you for presenting
this for him I do see that on the
existing bill there's already a
definition of segregated housing is he
potentially just removing that mass
deportation of immigrant
section because um if you go from secary
at housing and then to the new section
ordering the National Guard then that
would look like maybe it was just
removed you're right I'm sorry I missed
that no thank you for interpreting this
on the flag thank
you
okay representative Howard thank you uh
I mean this I don't know if this would
be more of appropriate to bring up
during an executive session but um as
for uh in paragraph one uh it talk about
detaining immigrants I'm just wondering
if it would be worthwhile adding because
this isn't an official uh Amendment yet
uh arrests as well just because of uh
some of the federal uh legislation that
has just recently be been passed
um sorry are you talking about the
amendment uh yes it's yeah do you it
says enter into contract cont to detain
immigrants
um I think this conversation we might
have with representative long okay thank
you I mean he's he chose this language
because he felt that it was more
indicative of what a contract should
look
like and I believe it would be uh
inadvisable to uh vote on this bill and
L representative long we're here that
will be I appreciate that thank you so
much all right is there any other
questions for representative
BR all right seeing
none this is largely a technical rewrite
right there's
no the attent is the
same all right anyone else well there
isn't anyone else so uh I will close the
public hearing on House Bill 4
e
e e
right being 11 o'c I'm opening the
hearing on House Bill 598 and I call
Representative Coran
thank you um so as we all know there are
various right to know laws both at the
federal and the state level here in New
Hampshire we have RSA 91a which is
wonderful um and I've used RSA 91a
multiple times in doing requests at the
Town level and this has allowed me to do
a lot of interesting stuff like uh
expose a illegal classification system
uh discover illegal meetings and other
things so um there's going to be you
know questions I imagine of hey don't we
already have this I'm fully aware of
what we have and I want to talk about
something new there are some problems
with RSA 91a which is that first of all
citizens need to know what they're
looking for and uh sometimes even when
they know what they're looking for they
can request it and uh the law requires
that um government employees respond
within 10 days but one of the things
that they can say is hey it's day nine
and I'm here to tell you it's going to
be 16 months until you get what you want
the other thing uh that is a problem is
each and every request that comes in uh
puts additional labor on the government
employees who are responding to it um
and that is an actual real cost and
that's one of the reasons that things
often stack up and go very slowly and
the uh another problem is that when
things come back they are often scanned
um they're you know misaligned Etc not
machine readable so in the private
sector uh I have run some small
companies and you know even as far back
as the year 2000 so a quarter of a
century ago anyone who spins up the
smallest of companies with a website and
get software packages you're selling
T-shirts or Pottery or something and
you'll get to see a corporate dashboard
updated in real time how many people
visited the website how many people
lingered on the page for at least 60
seconds how many things went into a
shopping cart how many shopping carts
were abandoned and you can do the other
thing on outflows using you know quick
in and other tools uh show me exactly
where my money went show me the average
time in between invoicing someone
getting
paid and uh if you're a good business
person you can use this to great effect
say Hey you know my advertising is
obviously working tons of people are
coming in but you know here's the
problem so um there is no equivalent
when it comes to either state or local
government with this there are a few
things that you know attempt uh so for
example the New Hampshire Department of
Education has some statistics on saus
and uh when I look up where for example
the most recent data is I believe seven
years old and um it is also in the form
of graphs and graphs are nice um but
they are you know they're human legible
but they're not machine legible so if I
wanted to spin up a simple you know
10line software script that was going to
uh pull down say the school results for
every school in Hillsboro County or all
across New Hampshire and then also go
over to the Department of Revenue and
pull down all of the data over there
about um taxation levels per you know
thousand of assessed property this is a
thing that in uh many areas of the world
you know I can um scrape data for you
know uh Journal articles on physics Etc
I can you know go to the federal
government and there has been a federal
initiative that is at least 15 or 20
years long where they have defined XML
standards and all sorts of data and New
Hampshire is behind in this area um so
uh and I just want to pull out a few
things um that I think uh could be
useful uh so there's a lot of debate
about how well does dco have to do its
job and we've had some legislators who
you know sort of alleg big conspiracies
and everything um and I I think it's
very plausible to be interested in the
question without necessarily alleging
anything and so several years back my
wife and I uh brought in some foster
kids and we tried to work with DCF and
um it didn't work very well and so uh
you know I have some questions of hey
was this a oneoff or how well does this
organization work so um I would like to
see for example uh DCF how many children
are taken into foster uh care every year
how many are you know reunited with
their parents within 12 months how many
of them once they're in dcyf custody uh
are given a doctor's appointment and
gotten up toate on their immunizations
uh many of these children you know
obviously have real problems they
wouldn't be in DCF care if they weren't
how many of them have seen a therapist
within 30 days or 60 days or 90 days in
Private Industry numbers like this are
often referred to as kpis or key
performance metrics uh and there is a
mantra you get what you measure so there
can be very uh low ranker discussion
about what exactly should DCF uh be
doing there's lots of different things
we might prioritize family reuniting we
might prioritize uh children getting
good access to therapy Etc or in
policing what should we what metrics do
we actually care about in policing do we
care about number of arrests do we care
about Rehabilitation do we care about
average speed on the roads um if we were
to have machine readable and easily uh
capturable and downloadable data in
these things it would lead I suggest to
a lot more um both citizen awareness so
they could say you know hey I've been
grumbling about the police budget for
the last 10 years but I had no idea that
there were you know 17 arrests that
turned violent and that's why you know
the tasers were actually a good thing um
and in DCF instead of you know having
allegations we just say hey DCF did you
know 45% of children were reunited with
their parents is that trending up or
down it seems to be flat is perhaps that
something we want to look at so um there
are all sorts of data that are already
in the system and this is the lwh
hanging fruit we could put out
requirements um asking employees you
know I want you to compile uh you know
how many people were seen per day in the
state unemployment office or I want you
to compile this I wanted to go in that
format um but if we uh start defining
and telling people what data formats we
want what data we want uh to be in there
what regularity we want this to be
uploaded on we are potentially missing
uh sort of zero cost Gaines where this
data is already there so if I said I
wanted you know daily police reports it
might be that the police are compiling
monthly reports and submitting them to
the state police something like that
actually does turn out to be true um and
just as a quick aside in that direction
I've been talking to the local and State
Police they already engage in a data
reporting system with the FBI called uh
dibbers I believe um I've gotten an
example of that data format this is
something that with about 11 seconds of
effort per year someone in the State
Police already having all of these files
could just publish to a website so what
I'm proposing at this point is not a law
requiring that these things be published
but a study committee uh ideally
bipartisan that would uh do
investigation you know meet remotely
over zoom and then we could each you
know head off into our own directions
and contact DCF and say hey what's
statistics do you already have what
formats are they in um and then
hopefully that study committee could
come back and uh the chair and I
discussed ahead of time uh might this
want to have an expiration date and I
think that's a wonderful idea we
discussed ahead of time uh two years uh
I would support two years if that was
the best I could get uh I might suggest
three years and the reason for that is
uh ideally the output of the study
committee would be an iterative process
where a year from now there would be a
bill on the table saying hey we ident
ified 17 files that already exist please
let's just put into state law that they
must be exposed every year by December
31st um and then we've also you know got
leads on some other stuff that is maybe
not quite as well formatted or quite as
well defined and we could come back and
sort of uh you know slice the sausage
and get another bite at it you know with
a new law a year after that uh that is
my proposal and uh I would welcome any
questions thank you thank you
representative
Roa thank you um um so this the intent
of this study committee is to look at
data from all branches of government
right that's correct okay follow up
follow up and you had mentioned
um kpis
yes and are you talking about kpis as
measured by the agency or are you
talking about kpis as you deem necessary
absolutely the former the point of this
is to find data that already exists is
already being tracked and imposes almost
a zero cost on the agencies to
expose follow
up so
um might this lead
to
um
determining dup uh you know um
redundancy the possible that agencies
are are collecting the same data in two
different formats for example that is um
so uh certainly it's possible that you
know when we reach if the study
committee were to be established and if
we were to reach out and we said to DCF
please tell us your internal reports uh
what they look like how often they're
compiled um we might learn that division
a has a report that you know has pieces
one two and three of data we might learn
that division B has some other report
that partially overlaps
um the intent of this bill you know and
I mentioned not just the bill itself but
the the very expected followon is not to
sort of directly go after agencies and
reform them but merely to expose
information and uh that information
could then be used by citizens and
legislators in you know ideally a
non-confrontational way to say Hey you
know we never knew that DCF you know for
example had this issue with only 30% of
children are getting some sort
um but it could also as you raise uh you
know the thing also say hey wait a
second we found out that the state
police are patrolling this road um we've
also found out that the local police are
patrolling it there's redundant effort
there or we found out that there are
multiple different reports that are
reporting on the same thing um you know
I I don't want to presume exactly what
will be found um but I can imagine all
sorts of things and uh I I can imagine
not just potentially cost savings by
eliminating redundancy um but I could
just imagine uh that Downstream of this
we would have better utilization of
resources as both the citizens and the
organizations themselves uh got Fuller
access to the metrics that are being
collected thank you thank you all right
represent Howard thank you for uh taking
my question so this is a lot of
information and we're talking about
producing a report on by uh by November
1st 2025 so we're looking at maybe like
five six months uh of uh committee work
before the report's
created I'm not necessarily sure that's
enough time if we were going to be
looking at every single uh part of our
government and trying to compile this
information excuse me representative
Howard the amendment I'm getting to
delete the excess Senators would also
extend the
uh would also require a second report in
26 one in 25 and one in 26 okay and and
I strongly support that you're right you
know um the the goal with this bill is
just to get something out there get the
process started um I think that you know
one could probably study this for years
and keep finding more stuff yeah okay
thank you thank you okay other
questions representative Lon do you have
a question uh thank you madam chair and
thank you representative for bringing
this to us um to me it seems like what
you're trying to do is get clarity on
the data that's already available make
it so that this can be looked at so that
we can ask better questions and then
have better policy Solutions is that a
correct interpretation that is very well
uh phrased and yes exactly thank you
okay represent
G thank you so how do we handle data
that is
confidential I um so this commission uh
would merely find out what data exists
um I think that it might be written into
this bill but it's certainly been
written into other bills that I've
submitted in the past that eii or
personally identifiable information
should absolutely continue to be
restricted and nothing either in this
bill or in Downstream bills would ever
seek to weaken those protections thank
you thank you
okay other questions all right thank you
very much thank you very much rush off
to another hearing thank you oh good
enjoy uh
rep Gary Merchant
thank you madam chair and also members
of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Gary Merchant former representative uh I
live in clamont and I'm here
representing
myself you previously heard a bill
dealing with the prescription drug
affordability board and that dealt with
redundancy and I think there's
redundancy in States because what
happens within the agencies in my
opinion the various agencies have their
own silos and the data resides in the
silos in order to get from one Silo to
the other today it's very difficult to
do sometimes if not impossible I can
share with you a story I worked at the
medical center at Dartmouth for many
years we had a data warehouse so what
would happen is that departments would
like our agencies create data calls or
create ways to collect the data they
wanted or things that they would
normally have but the data was put into
the data warehouse which allowed for
multiple departments to to get to the
data provided they have access and
confidentiality to it so they could not
access the data unless they had the
appropriate authorization to do so I
think what I would say is this is a if
you want try to make the government more
efficient this is definitely one of the
ways to do it I would make a couple
recommendations to the committee though
in my time in the
house asking for three members for the
Senate is a heavy
lift if you can get one you'd be lucky
um the other one too is online 7 I think
it's important we have members in the
house but most likely there's members in
the house that have subject matter
expertise in this area and I would
encourage the house at that point in
time either through the speaker or
through the bill itself to put that into
the language but that's where I'm coming
from I think it's a great idea I think
it was actually floated around probably
be six seven years ago um it wasn't
there I think Dennis gay um commissioner
gay with the Department of Information
Technology with great person to reach
out to I believe there's already things
in place that they do today that they
could build upon so you don't have to
start from scratch so that's where I'm
coming from all right thank you very
much are there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
for your testimony thank you is there
anyone else who wishes to speak on House
Bill
598 okay I will mention that I'm getting
an amendment um
to delete the Senators extended by a
year add a second report I mean put in a
repeal date two years out at the end of
the session and get two reports if the
first report is exceptionally valuable
we can extend it if necessary but uh we
should have a
deadline
and is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on House Bill 598
represent gr I just have a comment on
the amendment if the chair would
consider putting members of both the
majority and the minority because it
won't be partisan it won't be bipartisan
unless we have both represented I okay
that's definitely a recommendation we
will uh write up our committee report to
indicate that this is not a partisan
issue by any
means all right does
it Mr Joy do you wish to testify or just
listening okay in that case I will close
the public hearing on House Bill
598 we can't vote on it till we have the
amendment and we have a nice long lunch
until 1 p.m.
enjoy
e
e e
testing
e
e e
good afternoon welcome back I'm opening
the hearing on House Bill 702 and I call
the sponsor representative
duet thank you Madame chairman and thank
you committee members I'm Fred duet I
represent Rockingham 25 the town of
Salem uh Hospital
702 which I'm presenting this morning or
this afternoon
sorry um addresses for police
retirees the
hours that they are able to
work after retirement now at
present they are I'm going to get the
exact
number bear with me for a second I'm
sorry
at present a retired
um law enforcement
officer can work a maximum of 1664 hours
a year by
rule um if they retired early enough if
right if that
is actually if they
retired ear uh before January 1 of 19 I
think is the cut off
something in any event a current retiree
is is at 135
1352 yeah okay so they're limited to
working basically 26 hours a week after
retirement and the intent of that is to
prevent a law enforcement officer from
retiring and then deciding that they're
going to take a position with that same
department or a department within a
state doing the same
duties which makes sense in totality
because that would eliminate the
opportunity for a new hire to come in
and uh give Revenue to the retirement
system and and keep funding that system
in
itself the problem is here is uh
nhrs has made with without Direction
basically it was a call for them
to not allow extra duty hours to have
extra duty hours so outside detail
traffic direction things like that not
the day-to-day policing that our law
enforcement officers
do um so they're counting a detail that
a retired member may take as towards the
1352 hours okay and the problem in that
is twofold
one present employees in the
system those extra duty hours which are
available to them to work those extra
duty hours and pay does not apply to
their retirement it's not a calculator
in their
retirement secondarily there's no
definitive language to guide the
retirement system
into singling out the language in
relation to extra duty pay or private
work
details so this piece of
legislation would lay that out clearly
in
statute I must say that this is a you
know we have an ongoing issue in in all
service Fields specifically specifically
fire and police
Corrections on retention of employees
recruitment of employees and this may
help in that vein to some extent our our
retirees some of them find themselves
going out of state leaving New Hampshire
we'd like to keep them here and the
communities would like to keep them in
the communities because they know the
communities working traffic and and
whatnot so it just makes a lot of common
sense so this would uh kind of
incentivize that also another peripheral
benefit is the communities all of them
that I know of uh charge an
administrative fee so it's a revenue
generator for the communities in
itself so this is a uh to be clear it's
it's not a cost issue this does not cost
the state a penny it does not leverage
anything other than the ability to
Define for the New Hampshire retirement
system that extra duty hours are not
part of that 1352
calculus so they can still work up to
1352 hours doing Street P Patrol doing
uh desk work whatever it is this is very
narrowly crafted for the outside detail
stuff special detail stuff and you'll
hear and I'm sure
uh uh officer gear will probably testify
to the fact and I know we've all seen it
I've seen it in my town of Salem where
you'll see uh construction going on and
we'll have a cruiser from pelum or
ainson or Hamstead or Windam in doing a
road detail in Salem
uh great
organizations a great uh Mutual Aid
Network amongst the towns but the fact
remains is we could have people living
in our communities our retirees people
that know the town that they worked for
doing those
details yet for the the limitations on
the hours
so I'll take any questions if you thank
you representative
CCH are you saying that if these hours
did not count towards retirement while
they were
active officers they should these hours
should not have any effect after
retirement that's the short version
right
absolutely thank you other
questions represent bro thank you I have
a question of the chair have we seen a
Bill like this before I'm just trying to
I know that we've we've had bills
about after retirement work
hours yes we haven't had one that
specifically deals with extra Duty okay
great thank you at least not to my
memory it was just the total hours that
made a
difference yes sir thank you madam chair
so uh when you when when
question was being raised uh you were
saying no representative set right and
Mark mavan was shaking his head also in
agreement with you U uh and so has this
my question is has this proposal been
vetted to make sure that it does not
conflict with what we want
representative the represent the Mr
Kavanagh will be speaking next right so
he should have that information well but
I'm asking representative set whether he
has vetted this I would defer I I would
let him thank you I I I would just again
say there's there's zero cost to the
state of the municipalities in this it
affects no one it's a allaround win for
all involved thank you thank you madam
chair okay thank you Mr Kavanaugh
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record I'm Mark kavar
I'm deputy councel and compliance
officer for the New Hampshire retirement
system as
we have our usual disclaimer we are not
for or against this bill uh it's a
policy decision for the committee to
decide but we just wanted to point out
uh one major area of concern and one
minor area
um the first concern is that this bill
should not be read that a
member can work 1352 hours or if granded
1664 hours and then work as
much special Duty as they want special
Duties are work hours and if we were to
find that over
time say a six Monon or a yearlong
period a retiree was averaging 40 or
more hours a week between their regular
and their special
Duty
then and if the
employers uh number for fulltime was 40
hours we would restore that person to
active service their pension would cease
and they would be re-enrolled as an
active
member so although
for certain members in tierc We do not
count compensation for special
Duty um for the purposes of enrollment
we we would count the
hours so uh otherwise you'd have someone
who go and say all right I'll work 26
hours a week pulling a regular shift in
the cruiser and then I'll work 30 hours
a week on special Duty you're working
for the city you're assigned
to the third party that has asked the
city to to lease you so so to speak um
uh because we've had situations and and
I and I'll tell you why we count the
hours for
enrollment we had situation
where uh there were sheriff's
deputies working two or three regular
shifts a week and the other two weeks
they were transferring prisoners
or the
federal uh court
system and that was special Duty and as
a
result if we were not to count those two
days that they worked and were assigned
to travel prisoners they'd only have
three days and not 40 hours and they
wouldn't be enrolled in the system at
all and so to just
treat uh special duty hours
consistently we would count those hours
into determining whether a
retiree had in fact returned to
full-time service regardless of what
particular classification the employer
made have ascribed to that person as
full or
part-time um so for instance if a person
was grandfathered and allowed to work
1664 hours that would be 52 weeks at 32
hours a week this bill would allow them
to work seven more hours of Special
Duty now in a particular week they may
work more the way our rules work and
this is uh expressed in an interpretive
memo for determining whether someone's
stated work schedule reflects reality of
their actual work in determining whether
they're above or below the full full
time requirement and we've kicked people
out of the system fell below this Rule
and we've required enrollment for people
who fall above the rule rule and the
rule is essentially and I shouldn't say
rule it's not administrative rule it's a
policy in an interpretive memorandum
that was issued many years ago but it
says
that if we were for instance you show up
an audit and we were to look and and the
employee say Well they're
part-time well show me their work hours
and we would say okay we're going to
look at your work hours over the last
year Well despite you having a
classification of part-time and a job
description that says you work 32 hours
a week the fact is over the last year
you've worked 40 hours a week your
fulltime and we're going to say it's um
it's
uh a case of the facts over the form so
to speak we're going to look at what in
actuality happened we take an an
employer's word for it say this is a
part-time person they their their job
description says they work X hours and
that's below what is considered
full-time for police is set by the
employer same for fire um
for um employees it's 35 for state
employees it's 37 and a half for
teachers it's just 30
um but we found that notwithstanding the
person's classific they were working
more hours and we've had members come
and say yeah you know I'm a part-time
employee I'm a point a 0. n or a08
teacher and 08 of the regular hours puts
me below 30 but here they've asked me to
fill in for this maternity leave and
that maternity leave and and in fact
over that school year I worked I
averaged more than 30 hours and we just
restored 5 months of service to someone
after the employer had said said no
they're part-time they're they're
scheduled to work you know 27 hours a
week and the person said that's not
right I ended up because of filling in
for people working more and she was able
to prove that she appealed the the the
the school was able to present their
case uh and in the end the the the
school district conceded that the
actuality of her hours exceeded what her
formal status was so that's a
long-winded way of saying I just we just
want to warn people that if over the
long run the course of 6 months or a
year the facts show that you're
averaging more than what is
fulltime we will restore you to service
if we know about it knowing about it is
a different question but you have to
report those hours that's a secondary
thing we're going to have to change our
reporting system so that special duty is
reported separately because this statute
just says special Duty doesn't count it
doesn't say they don't those hours don't
have to be reported to us reporting is
in RSA 100 a16 and the only work hours
of retirees that are Exempted from that
section are for elected officials so for
instance BFFs and um court security
officers are not subject to these annual
limits but we still have their hours
reported to us similarly we do not
subject people who are in full-time
optional positions like commissioners of
certain departments officials of
appointed to a fixed term who are not
required to enroll in the system well it
would be silly to say well you have a a
limit on your worktime hours if you're
allowed to work full-time and not be a
member um so those exempt people still
have their hours reported to us they're
just flagged in our system as exempt so
we don't try to assess them a penalty so
these hours would still need to be
reported To Us by the employer and so
we're going to have to set up a
bifurcated system for group twos where
they could separately report and the
last thing is is is a more of a uh kind
of a a conceptual thing but um it might
be possible that employers the number of
full-time jobs might decrease if they
could fill it with part-time so if I
have someone who can work 39 hours a
week and I don't have to pay him a
pension pay pay pension contributions
versus someone who works 40 hours a week
I have to pay pension contributions and
person can say I'm going to do way with
that full-time position in hire a
retiree who works 39 hours a week which
was the State of Affairs before any of
these work after retirement um
requirements were put into place in 200
I think it was 15 or 16
um before that a retired police officer
could work 39 hours a week in and uh one
hour less than what's full-time and
still retain their pension um this is
essentially putting by not counting
special Duty putting some people back
into that position that uh everyone was
in prior to even having restrictions on
work after retirement uh with that I'd
open it up for any
questions thank
you with your
permission because I'm a co-sponsor on
this but there's been a question raised
as to the tierc and I I think we need
some clarification on the effect of the
TRC
folks um if that's all right that's okay
would yes are new people need to know
who who or what is tierc tierc means
uh persons who were hired on or
after July 1st
2011 so Mike my question in reference to
the tierc folks is followup well that
wasn't right you asked him that question
but um
is because the tier C extra special duty
hours do not count towards calculating
their
benefit right the compensation paid for
those hours don't count does not count
right because it does not
count
why would it
matter that that it in specific to the
TRC folks why would it matter then what
their ACR hours are in this particular
case when they've never paid in under
this category and they and they will and
they receive no benefit for work that
was conducted under this category um
well it doesn't matter to me or to the
system but you have two competing policy
objectives that the committee has voted
on and perhaps this issue is uh a time
to reconcile how they're different one
is are we going to allow exter special
duty pay to be included in calculating
the members benefit and I think the Poli
policy decision was back in
2011 when uh the definition was changed
of earnable comp because there was a
sense that a lot of people did a lot of
special duty at the end so their High
three years would be boosted up and
their pension would be higher that was
one policy consideration the second
policy consideration
was was it right or wrong to allow
members to retire and continue to work
at a level that's one hour short of
fulltime and a decision was made on a
policy basis um that there should be
some restriction on the number of hours
that a retiree can work once they've
started to collect their benefit those
are the two separate in competing policy
considerations for the committee to
reconcile I'm not saying one is good one
is bad I'm saying the state of the law
as it is requires a one result in the
case of not counting the compensation
because that's what the law says for
tier C members and in the other side is
the limitation on the annual hours two
separate subjects there's a little bit
of overlap here we don't take a point of
view on it it's a policy decision for
the committee to resolve amongst
themselves thank you representative Lam
um thank you madam chair and thank you
for being here to answer questions um
with with what you had told us about how
these extra and special Duty pays or
sort of the equivalent within the group
one employees can be used to the benefit
of the employee so that they qualify for
the retirement system would it be
inconsistent then to ignore them after
retirement to when it's at the benefit
would that be an inconsistent opinion to
say that those extra hours do count you
to full- time in one case and they don't
count you to fulltime and another I
think that's a matter of opinion and
policy that I don't have a position on
thank you and nor does the system um I
have a question sir the this bill just
says retied U law
enforcement oh does but it it is not
restricted to group C there are I know
there are some right middle group middle
tier people who are still
employed still in the retirements and I
suspect there may be some older ones
from
group there are still some tier a as
people who were vested as of um 112
which meant they had at least 10 years
service so that would have been someone
hired in 200 to 23 years ago there
there's there's quite a few police
officers especially lieutenants and
captains and Chiefs who was still
working after 23 years and then there's
tier B which were people who were hired
before uh 71 11 but did not have 10
years of service there's a lot of those
left I don't know the exact number but
it's around 1,600 and so for those two
groups special Duty does Count Their pay
does count towards calculation of their
pension okay well that appears to me to
be a flaw in the logic of this this bill
because it
should by their logic only apply to tier
c um would you agree with that no that
again that's a policy decision okay
there's a difference between counting
the compensation towards calculating the
benefit versus counting the hours for
the purposes of the limitation thank you
all right representative
BR so originally um we were we Define
these hours of work so that there
wouldn't
be um someone who's
retired come back to the
workforce and
work in
a in a Time beyond what
was
defined uh
right person could work up to one hour
less than what the hour the number of
hours that would make mandatory
enrollment correct yeah so and that was
to make sure that there was an abuse of
the system or maybe that's something
we're going to talk about in committee
but this would make that those
hours it would allow the expansion of
those hours
up up to one hour less than or or
theoretically one minute less than what
is fulltime for for group twos okay
thank you
okay interesting thank you very much are
there other
questions thank you for your time all
right excuse me representative citec has
a question yes sir Mr Kev you've you've
given a lot of examples I wonder just
how many people are affected but let's
get back to T sa you said somebody um
riding in a patrol car uh if he works 40
hours a week right now tier C let's
let's confine this to tier C if he works
if he's riding 40 hours in a patrol car
and does traffic Duty unrelated to his
core job that doesn't
count we you're right we would not count
the compensation nor would contributions
be paid on that contribution on that
compensation I want to go back to my
First Fundamental question because I
haven't seen how how that how you've
addressed that why that same person
retired those hours are not part of the
system they didn't count he got paid for
it as if he were working at Dunkin
Donuts for that matter so if you're to
unless this is some kind of end run
where he works 26 hours core and then
pretends that the other hours are
special duty but he's really doing the
same job I can see that as an abuse but
if he's doing special
hours what it just doesn't seem to it is
not and it doesn't seem it isn't
consistent that it's okay it doesn't
apply to his retirement before while
he's working extra hours toce
fulltime why those hours after
retirement should have the similar sum
effect on his retirement they didn't
before why should they
after well I don't ask should questions
those are policies what should or
shouldn't happen is in the purview of
the committee I don't have an opinion on
that you're you're excuse me leaving the
question you're leaving that up to us
correct as I should thank you thank you
represent LE um thank you madam chair um
right now if there's a patrol who is in
a role where there's a 40-hour work week
and they're working 32 hours in their
normal Duty um as a patrolman and then
they add another 10 10 hours average in
the extra and special duty pay is it
true that those dollars don't go towards
the retirement system but the fact that
his regular pay regular duty hours plus
the extra and special Duty add up to 42
which is over fulltime qualifies him for
the retirement system when he would not
otherwise
qualified well it's a a good
hypothetical question we haven't faced
it we've had no TRC members this
situation I described with the prison
transports was unique to straford County
uh and their Deputy
sheriffs uh when they raised the issue
that I'm being assigned to prison
transport two and three hours a week and
then I'm working 40 hours the same as
everyone else but I I only have regular
hours that are less than what allow me
to be enrolled so it was a unique
decision I think if your hypothetical
were to come up there would be some
serious thought about um what the proper
way to handle that was if that's any
guidance to you folks and making your
policy
decisions thank you that just just to
note Madam chair that a representative
PE to you a tierc employee is not
eligible to retire the very first one is
not eligible to retire until
2036 then this bill is to is only for
the tier A and
B retirees who
are whose special Duty does count to
toward did count toward that would be a
correct analysis yes thank
you anything further no thank you very
much that's been very
useful all right
Michael
G good afternoon Madam chair honorable
members of the committee my name is
Michael gear and I'm the New Hampshire
Police Association president I'm here
today to express my strong support for
HB 702 which seeks to exclude extra duty
hours commonly referred to as details
from the yearly calculation of hours
worked for retired part-time police
officers as you may know retired
part-time officers often continue to
serve their communities in various
capacities however under current
regulations their outside Detail hours
are counted against their yearly
allotted
hours it should be noted details worked
are not paid for by the local community
they're paid for by the local
contractor this practice can result in
unnecessary restrictions on the time
officers ability to continue to serve
their Community within a calendar year
it's essential to note that there is no
statutory requirement for the retirement
system to include extra duty pay in the
calculation of an officer's retirement
benefits furthermore details or extra
duty pay are no longer considered when
calculating an officer's retirement
benefits considering this it is only
logical that these hours should not be
counted against a retired parttime
officers yearly allotted hours this
change would not only be fair but also
provide more flexibility for these
dedicated public
servants the benefits of this bill are
twofold first it would allow retired
part-time officers to continue serving
their communities without facing
unnecessary restrictions second it would
allow local police departments to
confidently rely on these officers to
perform outside details if needed and
necessary I want to emphasize that this
bill comes at no cost to the state or
taxpayers it is a common sense
adjustment that would have a positive
impact on the local police
departments our retired part-time
officers have dedicated their lives to
serving and protecting our communities I
urge you to support 702 thank you for
considering my testimony I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you
representative re has a question thank
you and I'm sorry your your title what
am I supposed to call you again was it
the New Hampshire Police Association
president I'm also a detective with the
Salem New Hampshire police detective
then okay thank you very much detective
I sorry didn't hear that earlier uh
follow question thank you um I come from
Hampton uh I'm knew this this term we
have a significant problem in our town
during the Summers attracting part-time
police officers um and many many many
positions go unfilled uh which then
causes our full-time officers to have to
work over time
um if this bill were to pass would we
have a hard would we find ourselves in a
position in my town of Hampton during
the Summers would we find it easier to
hire retired part-time officers to fill
those shifts thank you thank you for the
question so in my humble opinion
whatever you're hiring in Hampton
there's two folds to this one if it was
paid for by the town of Hampton that
could actually count towards what the
full-time officer is paying however if
your local bar is paying a bill for the
police officer to be present that's
considered a detail uh Duty that will
not be paid for by the town because it's
a an extra Duty that a regular full-time
police officer that would be
contributing to the retirement however a
part-time officer those hours should be
outside that scope thank you you're
welcome all right
I have one Madam chair if you're yes
searching um there was some discussion
about um officers working say a 32 hours
and then using eight hours of of detail
pay or to get them to 40 I know in in
the fire service side of that that's not
how things work and I don't think it
works that way in your Universe either
if you're going to be a full-time cop
you're working 40 hours full-time
correct and these and I just want to
make sure that that's clear to the
committee that my understanding is
correct at least if I'm that this is
those hours on the extra and special are
not what makes you become full-time
correct correct um full-time police
officer has to work 40 hours a week
sometimes they pick up extra details
when it's available we rely heavily on
our part-time offices especially during
the summer uh the holidays uh however
they run out of hours because the detail
hours that they're working a security
detail it's actually being taken out out
of their um allotted hours for the whole
year so it's probably best and it's
beneficial if we separate those hours
from town time paid for by the town or
reg uh detailed uh time paid for by the
contractor or a special
Duty thank you for that other questions
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I
thought one of the concerns was not
you've emphasized several times in your
testimony that the the the payment is
not coming out of the public pocket it's
coming out of the private entities need
for service but I thought one of the
concerns was not so much that aspect but
the fact that here they are basically
working fulltime but but no
money not the appropriate amount of
money anyway is coming uh is going into
the
nhrs thank you for that um so and again
if it's a small town that's providing
the service a parttime officer providing
the service for a smaller town again the
pay if he's working or she's working a
patrol shift that's actually could be
considered a payment towards the New
Hampshire retirement system however a
police officer today which is TSC those
officers did not contributing Detail
hours they're not contributing to the
retirement system however we're almost
like penalizing the part-time officers
for wanting to work and being out there
providing that service that a full-time
officer doesn't want to
work thank you thank you other questions
thank you for your testimony thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
702 yes yes we do
all right seeing none I will close the
public
hearing I believe this bill will go to
the pension subcommittee for further
discussion to crystallize the policy
decisions sure um thank you madam chair
um I just wanted to make it clear that
some of the questions I'm asking are
clarifying because so many of us are new
to the committee and a lot of times the
people who are here as experts are
answering these questions well for us I
just want to make sure that I'm tying up
whatever loose ends I see so that we can
all get up to speed and really be doing
a good job as quickly as possible so
when they've been answered by somebody
it's helpful we already have that
information so thank
you have you talk
support I don't know if you heard no
stay stay
stay I don't know if you heard he said
the complication of keeping these hours
separate and I thought to myself wanted
to say well representative Schmid's in
the bill that said that
teachers attendance bonus would count
you were able to count those weren't
you to
because he was making the case at one
point
in
that
e
e e
yes I do I think we he should
be all right I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill
727 and I'm calling on representative
Pearson to introduce the bill since he
has said he is willing to answer
questions well yeah thank you madam
chair for the record um Representative
Steve Pearson Rockingham District 13
which encompasses the town of dairy um
I'm happy to introduce this on behalf of
Representative foot uh he's currently
upstairs in uh committee
Services um acquiring an amendment that
was supposed to we were told was going
to come down here and be ready so um in
the interest of getting things going
forward i' be happy to do that house
bill 727 is uh
extraordinarily similar to House Bill
436 from last term which went through
the house with a veto proof majority uh
was inserted into the budget and was
subsequently removed by the
Senate um the overall encompassing
reasoning for the bill is to address
retroactive changes that were made in
2011 to the group two
system ho wow killing
trees the like I all right so yeah so
the the the purpose the purpose of that
of this um is to address changes that
were made retroactively to the group two
pension system in
2011 the rewrite
Amendment um that is hot off the presses
here which which we should pass out yeah
um just is the result
of uh a stakeholders meeting that
occurred um just to to clarify some
language uh that that uh exists now as
you know at when two years of time
transpires and you have a bill that has
a lot of dates in it dates have to be
wiggled and adjusted
in order for things to work um and you
know there was a couple of policy
tweaks this this
is this is not right this is the wrong
one she get she printed off the one that
you already had yeah yeah so this this a
wrong Amendment
but anyway I'm more than happy
regardless of of that I'm more than
happy to answer any sort of questions
anybody has as far as technical what do
we do it's not the right Amendment
recycle it
yeah so as far as far as the committee's
questions
go we can I'm certainly happy to talk
about any historical aspects any sort of
technical questions any sort of
reasoning as to why something is the way
it is but the as I said before the
intention here is to is to
return some some not all some of the
benefits that were taken away in
2011 this does not enact a new
benefit at all there are no new benefits
that are being created from this this is
just in reference to changes from 20
2011 thank you representative CA has a
question thank you so maybe I
misunderstood you but I thought you said
House Bill
727 was exactly was very similar to
House Bill 436 extremely similar okay so
and the so that's fine I do
remember with the clarity House Bill 436
since it spent so much time in this
committee last year
why then what would the amendment
do why are we not going forth with this
bill uh this when this was initially
filed remember the filing period was way
back this was filed in oh my God
September right so since that time
period there have been a couple of
things that have changed we elected a
new
governor we had some stakeholder wiggle
arounds with some folks involved in
representing their various groups and
after this filing occurred a there were
stakeholder meetings that occurred to
for them to discuss some of the
concessions that occurred in House Bill
436 right because House Bill 436 as as
well as House Bill 727 has concessions
in it it is not a full
restoration so the the stakeholder
groups
amongst themselves discussed their
desire and willingness to agree to
certain
concessions
followup so are you saying then um the
amendment takes what was in 427 which is
what it was in
and reduces the concessions returns it
more to what it was like before correct
it returns it a little bit more to its
original if you will the purist concept
of of a full and complete restoration
which is actually impossible now because
so much time has transpired from this if
this had been
addressed four years
ago that you could have in
theory restored everything but because
of the progression of time now folks
that are in group two have been forced
to work additional years simply because
time has progressed and this hasn't been
fixed
yet that's a huge concession when you
when you prohibit someone's ability to
retire and force them to to work longer
that is a substantial concession so and
that has just happened due to the nature
of the movement of time
so last year when we were talking about
this we had
a some sort of committee I don't
remember the name of it but it had
members of the senate members of the
house I believe represent our chair was
on that committee correct as long along
with state
representative Jeff goalie and I
recognized some of the gentlemen in the
back of the room they were also on that
was a commission yes it was a commission
and is that what
is that what that thing that we all
agreed on because I remember Senator
gray and Senator Bradley negotiating
back and forth so we ended up with
something and are you saying that that
something was not was killed in the
house was killed in the Senate is that
what you're saying because I no that is
not what I'm saying okay so H Bill 436
when it went through the process two
years
ago it was inserted into the budget this
is two years ago during the normal
budget process it went through passed
the house was inserted into the budget
went over to the Senate the Senate
removed it from the budget that was all
exactly two years ago like right now the
over the summer what they did was a
commission was set up to look not at the
holistic problem but parts of the
problem and that summer commission and
you are correct there are people in this
room that were on that summer commission
that commission came up with
some ideas that were bits and pieces
that were potentially
doable for that moment in time okay and
as with all
commissions commissions issue majority
reports they issue minority reports this
entire mess that we're in right now came
out of a Minority
Report so you have to be careful when it
comes to the way commissions work
because people will pull things out of a
commission Bring It Forward and say hey
this is from the commission when in
reality it's from The Minority Report of
a commission
so that what happened last Su over the
summer was was well after the budget
process and in and did not it was not a
holistic view so so don't confuse the
two events um as they're not they don't
equate to each other followup so what
happened to the majority position it's
in you'd have to read it it's in the
commission
report but there's no legis followup
there's no legislation that is being
brought forward the the the minority
position is being brought forward in
this bill no this bill has nothing to do
with the summer commission okay yes
various pieces from the from that
commission were brought forward uh I did
a couple of them and not some were
approved and some weren't but they were
definitely bits in
pieces yes representative groa excuse me
representative land uh thank you madam
chair um you stated that something
passed the house with a veto proof
majority and I'd just like clarification
on what that was was it the same
language as in this bill or was it
something else so it was House Bill 436
that was passed by a veto proof majority
of the house when it was put into the
budget um it is
almost the same I mean you I we'd have
I'd have to sit there like
um I don't I don't if you really want to
go through sections I I don't know that
we need to but um yes it's it's 90% the
same okay is a followup follow up follow
I'm just trying to understand because I
had pulled up the legislative history
and when it when it passed as its own
individual bill that was it had actually
replaced with $50 million to pay down
the debt and that's what the Senate um
ended up um inter I'm studying but um
looking back previously I see that it
was a Voice vote um when it with the
committee report but I'm not seeing it
oh sorry thought to pass with Amendment
that's what happens when I start to try
to play this on the Fly that's what I
was trying to tease out it was amended
yes I'm sorry if I yes it was 436 as
amended there was there was some tweaks
to it but yes it did pass um with a veto
proof margin but again that's that's two
years ago this is today but that is
that's the historical derivative of 727
now is it came from House Bill
436 there's no sense in Reinventing the
wheel here we that was something that
worked um the
stakeholders got together and agreed to
certain concessions to make this work
right because obviously we have to
there's a goal here and it has to fit
within a within a budget frame as well
you have to be
realistic okay thank you
a followup thank you madam chair and um
you you're stating that concessions have
been made does this is this a final move
or assuming that this passes will there
be attempts to come back and get closer
to uh what tier B um wants to see so one
of the things that has come forward is
and I'll use uh the speaker's own
words Final Fix we've we've heard the
term over Final Fix Final Fix final fix
this I I will tell you represents a
final
fix thank you good to know repres Lon
and thank you and that's the final fix
for tier b um there's still a whole
another class of employees that don't
have the same benefits with so correct
and there's a difference here so in the
as we're using the tier a b and c
monitors now tier C folks the conditions
to which they were hired is the
conditions to which they operate under
whereas in the tier a folks same thing
the conditions to which they work under
are the conditions to which they were
hired under only tier B has that been
different so this does not involve any
and honestly any changes to a tier C
folks is the institution of a new
benefit and that fight is for certainly
another day if if we can you know if we
as we discuss and argue the the package
the the pension system as it exists for
folks hired after July 1 of 2011
that this does not touch them in any way
that that's a fight for a whole another
generation of
people thank you represent
broa so there I remember the fiscal note
for House Bill 436 but I don't see one
here so I'm hoping that the New
Hampshire retirement system will speak
to that okay yep the
um the fiscal aspects of
this uh are are twofold
one um is the 727 is amended version
which the retirement system does not
have a fiscal note on because it was
created 72 hours
ago they they may have one on the
initial bill that's fine the other
element of this is that for all of you
that have paid attention to the
governor's inaugu address the governor
has made this clear that this is a top
priority for her what her language is
what this looks like from the governor's
office no idea we'll all find out in the
end of next week when the budget's
released but um so there's
certainly however it is that the budget
writers create the budget there's
there's all of that so um you know and
ultimately I think that the prudent
method to move forward with this is
certainly through the the budget process
if this is if this is how that's being
introduced to the legislature is through
House Bill 2 then that is really the
mechanism that is most
appropriate to to address this
but this is a policy committee there is
policy here
and that is what's being conveyed here
the money part of this is is way outside
our lane on this
one okay other
questions all right thank you very much
and thank you representative foot for
your efforts yeah he was brilliant yeah
didn't say anything wrong thank you m I
apologize for the confusion with the
stair
okay Mr
Kavanaugh we will be if you have a
fiscal note we'd love
it Madam chair members of the committee
if you please again for the record my
name is Mark Kavanaugh and I am Deputy
counsel and compliance office for the
New Hampshire retirement
system uh we do not have a fiscal note
because we just received the actuary's
report last night I can speak to some
general numbers on that we will have
something well we we were going to have
something by the end of the week to um
LBA but now if there's an amended
version our actuaries would need to see
if that changes any of their um uh
numbers it sounds like it's mostly
housekeeping and language type of
changes but we need to run it by
them
so before we get into the financial I
just want to mention very briefly the
legal
considerations um there were um
ambiguities
clarifications that would be needed
things we were uncertain about because
of the language used uh uh for instance
why use a September 1st cut off date
when existing law was based on January
1st um but there there's probably a good
reason for that but we we don't
understand the exact um purpose behind
uh the sponsors but these are things
that can be
resolved uh and the language could be
ironed out and perhaps that's better
suited
for a subcommittee level after the
financial considerations have been uh
reviewed by the committee and there's a
desire to move forward so I don't want
to take up time with a lot of technical
jargon and these are complicated bills
trying to change multiple Provisions
across the whole spectrum of our statute
um even the experts who've been doing
this for a long time would struggle to
get it right on the first try and and
again that's something we can work
through and figure out what language
accomplishes what the sponsors want to
accomplish if it's the committee desire
to move forward um with respect to the
financial considerations I would cave on
anything I'm about to say uh that these
numbers may change based on whatever
amendments uh but in general um the bill
at as currently written has a positive
effect on the finances of the system it
would result in a very nominal decrease
in the police and fire rates of less
than
0.5% and it would result in a a
reduction of the underfunding of around
10 or 15 million
doll uh but this is all predicated on
the state paying $ 27.5 million for the
next 10 years beginning July 1st in the
absence of those
payments employer rates for police and
fire would go up about three to 4% and
the unfunded acred liability would go up
by 110 million so as written it has a
positive effect um assuming it's funded
as
intended uh that's all I have to say
today uh we'll Endeavor to get uh once
we see it an amendment we'll Endeavor to
get a finalized fiscal not workk sheet
to the committee so they can see the
actual numbers I don't suspect they
would change a lot given what uh
representative Pearson has described as
language changes and the like um with
that I'd open that up to any
questions
representative sorry representative
so the the document you're referring to
is in place of the one that was passed
out and then rejected because it's not
the right document yeah I'm going by the
bill as
introduced thank you that's clear enough
we all know what that is in other words
the Pete the document we were provided
with originally for today yes I assume
so
yeah thank you okay and it does include
the 2 7 million per year correct and so
we will we will be delighted to see that
happen other
questions thank you very much I
easy John mallister
good afternoon chairman uh chairwoman
Maguire and The Honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is John
McAllister I'm a 25e member of the
nationville fire department and
currently serve as a secretary treasurer
for the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire uh reinstating these benefits
for our members has been and will
continue to be a priority of our
organization we uh have an we have an
understanding today that um the governor
is going to address this in her budget
and with that being said out of respect
for the committee as well as the
governor we ask this committee to retain
this this uh this bill
today okay be happy answer any questions
or I don't think there's any questions
on that thank you very much for your
testimony Frank
Campo I'll S A up yes please
all right good afternoon uh Madam chair
and committee my name is Frank Campo I'm
a sergeant with the state police I also
serve as the president of the New
Hampshire Troopers Association I'd like
to start by uh thanking this committee
for their dedicated work in the past on
retirement uh especially as it pertains
to group two two years ago this
committee um as well as the house
overwhelmingly passed House Bill 436 uh
which was a compromise that restored
many benefits that were taken away from
First Responders unfortunately that bill
did not get through the Senate um I
would like to thank representative foot
for bringing this bill here today um
which looked very similar to
436 and I am of the understanding that
the governor intends to address group
two retirement in her budget and in an
attempt to Not Duplicate efforts um we
are asking for this bill to be retained
in this
committee thank
you uh Madam chairman thank you my name
is James deur and I work with the New
Hampshire Troop Association and the New
Hampshire Police
Association um I wanted to just take a
moment because for some of the new
members there may still be a little bit
of confusion over what happened in the
past and why everybody is here today so
um as you have heard from representative
Pearson and others uh two years ago this
committee passed House Bill 436 which
was similar to this bill very
comprehensive Bill uh reinstating some
of the benefits that the middle
tier of group
two um lost during the negotiations that
took place 12 years ago so as you know
there are three different tiers to group
two there's tier a which are the many of
them are retired maybe most of them um
there's tier C which were the new hires
and then there was a middle tier and the
real issue that happened 12 years ago
was that the middle tier had been hired
with an understanding of certain
benefits and during that process they
lost some of the benefits they thought
they had been uh given when they were
hired so this has been sort of the issue
that has festered now for 12 years and I
can tell you that we really appreciate
the work that representative Pearson has
done for half a dozen years now on this
topic um and we as Frank said we
appreciate the work that this committee
did two years ago when the big Bill 436
passed um and unfortunately the Senate
did not pass that as representative
groda indicated when that bill came back
it was turned into a
commission that worked on Pieces of What
was was in 436 a year ago summer and
then this past session you did pass one
item which was changing the multiplier
provision for the middle tier so um as
you've heard from others uh Governor aot
has indicated that this is a priority
issue that we expect we will see in
either the budget or in House Bill too
um we do appreciate the work that her
staff has has done they have reached out
to the stakeholder group uh run language
bias we have not
seen the final version that will come
out next week but as Mr mallister said
and as Mr Campo said we expect something
will be in House Bill 2 um we think that
probably is the vehicle that makes the
most sense to focus on so if this
committee is willing we would also
support retaining this bill and using
House Bill 2 as the vehicle for dealing
with with
this thank you are there any
questions represent scitech don't forget
that ping card please I will get it
right to you thank you thank you seeing
no other questions thank you for your
testimony Gary Burke
good afternoon Madam chair and committee
members my name is Gary Burke I am oh
you have to be closer to the bike sorry
I gotta eat the mic all
right good afternoon Madam chair and
committee members my name is Gary Burke
I work for the New Hampshire State
Prison Department of Corrections I'm a
captain there I've been there for 20
years started in
2004 uh I appreciate the work that you
all have done on the prior Health Bill
last session I know we're here today to
talk about 727 I represent correction
supervisors I'm the president of the sea
for the correction
supervisors and I would also just like
to voice like the prior colleagues
before me uh that this bill could be
retained and that we try to look at what
the governor would like to attempt to do
with hb2 in the next coming
week appreciate your time and your
efforts thank you very much okay thank
you other qu
questions very good Cypher regasa
please turn your mic on ah thank you
good afternoon Madame chair and the
committee first and foremost uh i' would
like to take uh time to thank you all
for all you've done with our bill 436
and you continue to fix this middle tier
issue we have with an Isam retirement
system uh the issue we have was created
back in 2012 it continued to be a
problem it affects our Recruitment and
Retention and um I appreciate what house
representative fot has done with this
bill and what uh house representative
Pearson has stated previously uh I
recall the same message that was sent by
the previous
speakers um we have had a very good
understanding of what's going on now the
good Governor is coming with a plan to
address although I do not want to speak
for her or for her staff uh I know that
there is some discussion going on which
we feel that we can address this issue I
respectfully request if this committee
would retain the bill to allow the
opportunity to see what a permanent
solution a durable solution is proposed
by the good
Governor okay thank you for the record
my my name is saasa I am a chief provis
par officers and I'm the president of
the New Hampshire provation par
Association Command Staff Union
thank
you don't see any questions so thank you
again thank you very much is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
727 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing and I think we should go into
executive session representative Pearson
you have a motion as a matter of fact I
do my motion thank you Mr foot is is to
retain House Bill
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
I do as um for those of you that are
more seasoned folks in the in the
legislature when you have a piece of
legislation that is going to be
addressed in h Bill one or two this is a
procedural move to allow the process
that better fits the solution to take
charge and in every case it is to let it
go through House Bill one or two so that
is The Prudent way to go and it would
certainly apply to the situation that's
in front of us right now thank you
representative
SCH thank you manam Pier as one of the
members of the committee from back in
those days I'm glad to see that we are
moving in a more hopeful way to get
something that will be um more likely to
prevail
through through both bodies uh so I'm
happy to Second it all right does anyone
else have questions comments
concerns okay I like to mention that the
purpose of retain is so that we don't
establish a policy of killing the bill
but we don't have to work on it until
after the budget has completed going
through the house and the Senate and the
committee of conference and at that
point we can look at this bill and say
gee they left this part this policy
issue out we can and deal with it at
that or we can just say thank God they
took care of everything and we can just
quietly kill this bill that those will
be our choices after the budget has been
passed and as representative Pearson
said This is Not Unusual any other qu
comments all right the motion is to
retain the CL call the
role
yes thank you
uh the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey yes
representative shim yes representative
sers
yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt
I representative Davis yes
representative Dar yes representative
Howard yes representative St Rees yes
chair
yes I think that looks like uh 13 two
four 13 Z okay we have voted to retain
it and that's it I have an amendment for
House Bill 598 so since we're an
executive session we might as well go on
to that let me go get
start a new Green Sheet I thought I'd
have time to grab it down from the down
there
I appreciate
all
right
two okay we have
four all right I I move Amendment 285 H
to House Bill 598
Eight
Second thank
you repr Pearson that was a
second okay represent yeah my
ventriloquist skills are not that good
oh
good all right and this
amendment to the bill cleans up the
number of
members and
requires two
reports one a preliminary report no and
25 and a longer one in 06
and I've been assured by our legal
experts that since this is not a statute
it's chapter law that it doesn't need an
explicit repeal that the fact that the
final report is due in 26 means this
goes away in 26 I hope they are
correct you have to repeal a statute the
chapter law if if it's specifically to
do something through 26 it expires or so
I have been told
um in any event
it it's all the people that this struck
me as a very good idea to take advantage
of some of the ex knowledge and
experience of house members on data
because we do have a lot of people who
know about it and if they can identify
loow hanging fruit and information that
can be shared by departments without a
great deal of extra work I think that
will
improve both efficiency and transparency
and I'm in favor of both of those
representative LAN
um thank you madam chair I agree this I
believe this is a needed committee
commission so that we can have a better
handle on data and use the data that we
have to make better policy choices and I
think we have a quite the roster of
people that can serve on this committee
so I'm excited to see this
happen represent brto thank you I wish I
could support this amendment but I
cannot
because I had specifically mentioned
that if this is truly a bipartisan
committee M there needs to be
representatives from both the majority
and the minority in the house and and I
don't see that and the other there's no
mention of pii which is the Privacy
Information doesn't say anything about
that either and I do believe I asked
that question of Representative corkran
and he did tell me that he thought that
was an important
part ah those are both
both valid
concerns and in fact I will revi I think
I will take that to heart and revise it
thank you I very much appreciate
that all right in that case I will
recess the executive session until I can
get a better Amendment
and yes
sir I I have to say I very much
appreciate some some kind of revision
because uh as I sat and listened to
representative Corker and I thought
maybe when in two or 3,000 years when we
have uh when we
have standardized every other thing in
the universe other than that that this
kind of a you know incredibly
complex uh you know microscopic invasion
of every aspect of this whole subject
uh but this
version I couldn't support that okay
thank you we we will withdraw this am
we'll get a better Amendment and uh come
back later I I think that the point is
important but the words don't appear to
be
correct all
right all right end of executive session
we are off duty the uh board house
session tomorrow and there are a couple
of subcommittees meeting after the
session and then next Wednesday we have
um another day of hearings including our
friend the uh state flag the state
animated film and a few other and JCC
that's that's up on uh Wednesday also so
we'll have a full day
perfectly
e for